the headscarf on my head doesn't stop my
brain from working being female and
Muslim doesn't make me oppressed or
brainwashed you might disagree with my
choice to dress modestly that's fine
but that's exactly what it is a free
choice there's no single form of
feminism and to those women who think
Muslim women are oppressed and need
saving we've got a thing or two we think
we can contribute just look at how our
public space for example is highly
sexualized and we're particularly
worried about the impact on our young
women and girls so many women Muslim and
otherwise who adopt modest dress say
that it empowers them they feel relief
and freedom from sexualized imagery the
strong female only spaces that Muslim
women have created could give us the
chance to see how our ideas of beauty
and behavior could change and even
flourish under a female gaze in shared
public spaces clearly marked personal
zones are something missing women work
hard to assert it's something that
bothers all women just look at how much
debate the idea of women only carriages
generated but personally the practical
area where I think we have most to offer
the discussion is around the way we
support women and families through
motherhood and economic empowerment it's
all well and good for us to talk about
the end of sexism but this won't happen
until women are free from the gender pay
penalty the greater share of childcare
provision and the burden of household
maintenance that all women still carry
Aslam puts women and mothers at the
center of family life and insists that
the family unit and society is
structured around meeting the social
practical and economic needs of
parenting Muslim women face many
challenges and many of them are severe
we don't have it perfect and we haven't
resolved all the issues but then neither
has the wider women's rights movement
we've all got different ideas
perspectives and contexts but we've got
the same goal better lives for women and
men
you